biden unveiling his administration's
plan to combat racial injustice
in a speech to mark the 100th
anniversary of the tulsa race massacre
a horrific event that left more than 300
people dead
biden promising to spend billions on
racial equity
and asking americans to root out
systemic racism
so degen white americans belong to the
clan
and they weren't even embarrassed by it
they were proud of it
and that hate became embedded
systematically and systematically in our
laws and our culture
we do ourselves no favors by pretending
none of this
ever happened or doesn't impact us today
because it does still impact us today
to close the race wealth gap herald to
you first on this does spending
money the the massive amounts of money
really that he's talking about here in
other places
does that fix the problem i think it's
part of
helping to fix the problem i think
sometimes when we talk about racial
equity i think there's a sense that
we are saying the country's bad or we're
saying that white people are bad or
we're degrading people
when you can look at it narrowly that
way but i don't think that's that's what
it's really about if you look at what
happened in greenwood that that that
community was burned down greg and i
have an interesting conversation about
this before going on
that community was burned down it was a
successful community black community
economically
so taking efforts and targeting the
money and saying look
we as america there's no other country
in the face of the earth that can go
through this
and recover and and thrive the way we
we are and have the kind of
conversations that we have so if it
makes us a little unsettled a little
uncomfortable having a conversation
so be it as long as it doesn't come from
a place of malice as long as it comes
from a place of trying to make things
better
and i give him the benefit of the doubt
the president and his efforts to try to
do that
if the money turns out to be a waste and
they need to shift it reorganize and
redo it but
and at the start i think you give them
the benefit of the doubt you try to do
it greg to that interesting conversation
you had with harold from what we just
heard from president biden i'm the first
president in a hundred years he said
to acknowledge the truth of what took
place there in tulsa i was i had no idea
that i mean this was not taught to me
in in high school or college and i i was
thinking is it because i'm on the west
coast is that why
but it's you know it's a horrible story
i think it's important to talk about it
but that's a separate issue then from
this idea of equity i'm a
i'm an apostle apostle of thomas soule
so it's like
when they shifted from equality to
equity
it becomes a different story it's not it
everybody wants equality
equality of opportunity but we
understand that the
equality of outcome is impossible and
it's harmful
there are certain places where i will ne
the percentage
of five foot five white guys with an
ashkenazi background will not be in the
nba
there's maybe it'll be less than point
zero zero percent so we have to we have
to
we have to ask ourselves why are we
shifting from equality to equity and
it's because we realize that
discrimination to
deliberate discrimination is illegal and
we know that
it's not happening everybody in
corporations wants to hire minorities
colleges want minorities so then where
is the discrimination
it's before that it has to be before
that because we are seeing problems on
the street
we are seeing uh lots of issues
so it happens we are meeting this
problem too
late and that's where i go back to
thomas saul so he'll bring up three
areas
what are the three areas that have
negatively impacted black lives he'll
say the welfare system
destroyed the family he'll say teachers
unions um
killed competition school choice that
kills education
the third thing now would be the
de-escalation or the defunding of police
which now makes
communities where minorities live unsafe
so
government bureaucracy by liberals has
has
gone aft has hurt families schools
and communities that's what makes
everybody suspicious
like what can they do that can make it
worse and that's what you have to worry
about i guess
if i were a black american and you said
well you know i had my dna test i know
0.1
and if i see another white liberal like
joe biden coming around and saying how
they're going to help me
i would shake my head i mean for how
many years has
have white liberals said they're going
to help black america
and you still have the black poverty
rate twice that
what white poverty rate is black
unemployment rate twice what white
unemployment rate is
you have the black education gap it's
gotten bigger
you've had now less black families
intact
is any of that working what we're doing
i'm actually thinking now
when the government says they want to
help blacks they're actually hurting
blacks
because where the trillions we already
spent go joe where did they go did they
go to just the race hustlers that run
the federal programs that don't work
because they didn't go to the people
that needed the help
so if someone was saying i'm going to
help you i'm going to help you know i
say you know what i'm going to help
myself
i'm going to operate my schools my
businesses my families i'm going to keep
more of my money and i bet black
americans would thrive if white liberals
stopped trying to help them i think that
the teachers unions
let the education flourish exactly that
would be a big step and the democrat
party is behind it all because
they want to call black americans
victims when black americans are labeled
victims that means they need help from
white liberals
and help means votes you get votes in
exchange for help
once they're not victims anymore they
don't need help and then they don't get
the votes so you're going to see the
democratic party and i know you agree
because you're shaking your head yes
they keep playing the race card because
that keeps victimizing black america and
that keeps the democrats in power
and that's never going to change that's
never going to change so what if i told
you
what if i told you from 1920 to 1980 um
99 of all loans for homes
residential mortgages in the country
were only provided to white americans
and at 99.5 percent of those
providing that were the government and
it was an intentional effort on their
part and what if i told you the number
one creative wealth in any family
regardless of what you look like in the
country is in your home
now if you deny the numbers are what
they are and i think there was an
intentional effort i think part of what
he's trying to do and i don't dispute a
lot of the things you say about i mean i
when i hear liberals saying they want to
solve every problem i get concerned fact
when i hear anyone saying they want to
solve every problem i get a little
concerned but particularly in this space
i think finance economics we've got to
find ways to tell these stories to
remind people what happened and two
the things you mentioned are those three
things that mr sal mentioned there were
challenges before we were trying to
address them and the answers
weren't sufficient that doesn't mean we
we stopped trying i think we have to
continue to offer idea
after idea whether it's conservative or
liberal to try to solve this
i believe from 1920 to 1980 if just five
percent of that money had gone to black
homeowners
think about how many more black
businesses how many more black
homeowners how many because remember the
number one determinant for how well you
do in school
in this country public school is the zip
code you come from
regardless so if you had more money in
local communities more money would go
towards schools we're not going to solve
it all here in a minute and a half but i
think there's a lot
there's a lot more to it than what we
discussed and that does speak to
one of the words that you will hear from
black americans who are upset
about the about inequality is ownership
and it goes back to the tulsa massacre
it goes back to home ownership that's
that's something that that's a word that
you will hear and a message
you'll hear often but in terms of
liberals
look no further than the liberal bastion
of silicon valley
i talk about this over and over again if
you look at the percentage
of their workforce that is represented
by black americans
it is dismal it is appalling in
technical jobs
facebook has less than two percent
of people in technical jobs who are
black you mean to tell
me over the last 20 years or so or since
these companies were founded they
couldn't have done something about that
actually
going into high schools and pulling
people and
educating them themselves they're
starting to do that
but it's a little too late in terms of
what joe biden wants to do
it might be unconstitutional last week
there were two
courts that blocked joe biden's small
business administration
from handing out benefits based on race
it's 29
billion dollar restaurant relief fund so
you know who gets to the front of the
line
it is minorities and women at the back
of the line
it was everybody else and if it run out
if these that program runs out of money
before it gets to someone
who is a white man then you're out of
luck
and those those two pro two judges two
courts have blocked that program
so far because you know what bias and
discrimination
is wrong and unconstitutional regardless
of the group
and if you haven't seen the budget
proposal because it came out friday
friday late in the day before memorial
day you saw that it was in it hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else